you know I I have like a and you may
hate this but I have I'm kind of
obsessed with failed talk shows and I
didn't realize until yesterday and I'm
going I'm watching your old interviews
and stuff you've done on other radio
shows just a you know kind of and I was
like holy [ __ ] and I don't know if you
know this but did you know that Craig
was the original co-host of The Magic
Johnson hour you know what i if I knew
that I forgot it I don't think I ever
knew that so i heard i mean and and this
story about like you know how you were
put in a position to fail it's great i
heard heard the story do you have this
thing that you're in this business
because you want to basically get even
with the girls that wouldn't go out with
you do you have any other i have well so
understand that i got that show and that
was my get even when all the 13 girls
that shot me down for the prom this was
my mom i had a national TV show what
year is 97 okay it's only on one year it
was i remember the show I remember
imagine you had a show it was barely on
a month now did you you didn't last the
run though you want to hear the story
yeah I want to know how you got on my I
don't mind the story I wonder how you
got fired I'm gonna tell you okay so
they give me the show and they said this
was exciting I wasn't gonna be Ed
McMahon ha ha ha I'm the comedian that
he laughs at he gives me set up jokes I
thought that's a pretty cool tremens
said a hint doing a monologue I do the
monologue to him so they'd be sitting
head tester shows what you guys hate
chemistry it went really well great and
I got the part it's a whole bunch of
other common it's kind that part was
good it's kind of you getting to do a
show and magic is there to be the sort
of name value and a people in and I got
to tell the jokes and yeah but they
panicked and they brought in writers
from The Tonight Show right not the Leno
Tonight Show that Johnny cars and the
guy literally had a mullet cut and a
Members Only jacket by the way folks if
you're out there and wearing a Members
Only jacket I mean to offend you but
this is in 97 where it was like there
was no there's no irony to it it's just
Joe Dirt
and I literally he said these words to
me I said you can't make me tell these
jokes who said you have to tell the
jokes I called him Sling Blade II at
that time
we played without her right cut it out
ja that's how he talked I said
Slingblade you can't make me tell these
jokes I'll get booed he says to me mmm
boo is as good as a laugh Johnny love to
be booth Johnny Carson love to be booty
at all stick about it I'm not Johnny
Carson no one knows who I have you can't
make me tell these jokes you remember
any of these jokes oh I'll tell you what
it was well Jim as a stand-up do you
think boo laughter it's all the same as
long as they're reacting no I really
wish it was so what do you tell you so
so Slingblade also writes the intro so
I'm backstage making a list of all these
girls I hope or watching all Linda Scott
you made out with Ricky out amer at the
prom you were my date I'm thinking
you're gonna see me now god I'm about to
come into stardom right here's the intro
place is going nuts urban crowd that
means black yeah and I'm white and she
leaves the bandleader places go are you
ready for magic everybody's going crazy
and it really was that it's still on
YouTube they're good I love it so so
they here's the intro that Slingblade
wrote for me for magic to say all right
everybody let's get the show started
with my co-host now here's a guy nobody
would shower with Craig shoemaker now
see you think I'm backstage going I
don't think I'm coming out to that I
thought let's retake this that was that
was magics intro for you I had just won
you know these awards and that was it so
you go here's a guy no but it was show
Craig shoemaker so I come out by the way
of a horrible walk and I'm paranoid
about it's a bouncy walk and I'm trying
not to walk look like a [ __ ] what's
up can you say that yeah I get out to
the couch and this is the opening line
he says mostly urban crowd I'm white and
it my setup is and Slingblade wrote this
joke for me to say hey Craig how about
that Bulls game magic I haven't seen a
beating like that caught on tape since
Rodney King okay you see a reaction like
is it sensitive I am Telling You I
thought they were good there was a
collective gasp you could have heard
Europe here in New York from Paramount
Studios it was literally like this
wasn't it boo it wasn't a booth
we solve it so you got something
actually not a laugh not a boo worse
than either of worse than either like
like resuscitates did magic know that
joke was coming I don't know the answer
to that but I do know this he's known
for the assistant basketball but this
was his response Oh Craig
you are bad that was Craig not a
celebrity he didn't want to look better
Oh Craig you are bad now he's not gonna
come on the show and I'm sitting there
thinking that's not the reason I'm
selling you out sold me out never wanted
to look bad and then it was so funny
because it's a talk show but he had a
little difficulty in that area
Michael Clark Duncan was an Armageddon
and he's reading the cute cargo now up
next from the movie I'm a good dude to
DA now yes from I'm a good dude I'm a
good deed
Craig how you say that word I say just
say end of the world that's the end of
my life that that didn't did that make
air or did they edit it out yes I think
I made it to the air home I'm a good
dude did on did you ever get with him or
no well you know it kind of you know
he's a nice guy and everything and but
he mostly was in his dressing room so if
you saw him now would you guys talk over
the old days or would you just well I
don't know about that I haven't seen him
I go to the Lakers games I'm really
tight with the owner and so I go to the
games but I don't we've sorta never
really crossed paths I'm not really sure
he would know who I am I didn't last
very long
it didn't seem like he he did a ton of
work for his show magic like it seemed
like he's reading his teleprompter he's
doing what the writers tell him and
that's why there's a guy like Craig
there cuz you're there to do the heavy
lifting
well I that's funny he would have that
observation one of the things I observed
was he really you know to host a talk
show you really have to be you know
pretty broad have a broad spectrum in
your life things that you read and
things like that but so he's sort of
like had to make him fit they fit him
into that you know square peg or
wherever and so they said you have to be
a family man
so you know it's a guy who like you know
he lived the life in in in Los Angeles
not a family man life so like he would
say stuff like never have a coach on the
side and he would go now Sheila E that's
a really nice dress right and they're
going anyways how long did you last I
last well day three um
magic says we'll be back after this and
apparently that didn't include me they
came up and they whispering in my ear oh
you're gonna be off the couch now the
people upstairs decide you're gonna be
off the couch now you have to understand
you know this is a nightmare for me now
all the girls I think are gonna be right
I'm set that they didn't go to the
problem with me now they're gonna go he
got thrown off the couch this is
historical they told you in the middle
of the show and then I started arguing
and I said no I'm not you're not gonna
do this to me they said get off now and
they yanked me off of the couch now did
you get any reason really started
outside started puffing I was so upset
was it a bad segment before then
no had nothing to do it they had made
the decision before they said somebody's
sightlines or whatever and it was funny
cuz our CEO Hall was the first guest he
walks out and he goes where shoe he's
funny
just magic alone out there with a guest
yeah yeah and then they would put me in
like his I had a contractor who put me
in like the fifth segment the cooking
segment he would throw flour on me look
Craig you're a cake because I've read
what I read was like an article that was
like reflecting on the magic hour and
whatever you know ill-conceived idea it
was from the beginning but we could see
if it wasn't organic wasn't genuine the
article said that you got fired because
you went out and said the show was a
disaster or sighs and if I said which is
back in the day this was not like you
know there wasn't you know Twitter and
things blow up instantly back then I did
I talked to someone a reporter in
Philadelphia and they were one line they
were looking to fire me right they said
because it was ill-conceived like you
said it was I was the white guy mm-hmm
that was the other thing is they put me
in because we don't want it to be an
urban show
for every not organic nothing about it
was organic his agent was the executive
producer knew nothing about you know
television and I said it's too Titanic
and I'm bailing out with a shot glass
that's what that quote got out to Los
Angeles faster than it was the period
was put on the sentence and David said
you're at it and they're like we got
action we got him got him I lost $82,000
with that quote Wow yeah because I had a
payor play contract but they said that
you disparaged what other comedians did
they bring on after the you're gone and
the show lasts for a little while what
are the guys they're Steve white who was
always there anyways anyway and he's
black yeah ironically Steve white but
they brought him in and what was funny
was they were acting like I was
disparaging the show the first guest
when I was fired was Howard Stern who
completely like rips on the show isn't
if I had to go to work every day
listening to him replay I'm gonna lose
critical eye
powered had such a great time the Magic
Hour and he went on I mean it was it was
brilliant but this tells you Hollywood
how Hollywood can like throw their head
to the side on certain things but with
me to have all this integrity that he
hurt our show by saying it's a shot
given or whatever meanwhile Howard Stern
goes on it goes hey Madge you good fun
getting the AIDS didn't you me then yes
it's on YouTube did farting he did the
fart contest it was like unbelievable
and then magic just sat there oh come on
Howard I mean it was it like and I was a
kid at the time but like I was always
obsessed with stuff that I knew is a
disaster like ever since I was a little
little I've always loved stuff that I'm
like oh this is gonna end poorly and
like Howard would talk about on the
radio all the time every week it was on
Fox and every week also on Fox
MADtv would do spoofs of it where Aries
Spears I know and a guy played me who
played you what was his name he was so
good too I mean which kind of that kind
of stuff makes me laugh though I mean I
love when people imitate me but Aries
Spears would do a great man yeah we
would sit there he'd mispronounce every
word and he would be looking at the
wrong camera I was like abused on the
show it was awesome and then they
replaced magic
with was heavy chase no no no no you got
that wrong wait was it the other way
Chevy Chase had his own show and he
lasted shorter time the magic Chevy show
last that lasted like about two months I
think cuz I love that too it's just a
disaster that was the same era Chevy
Chase's was absolutely horrible horrible
and this lasted a little longer because
they brought Tommy Davidson replaced
Steve white and then they ended up
giving the show to Tommy Davidson pretty
much well it was called the Magic Hour
but still it was it's clearly Tommy
Davidson show yeah just do one bit after
another you know he was good right I
mean yeah he's a great talent yeah he's
funny he's definitely I don't know if
he's any Magic Johnson
how long did magic last magic probably
lasted three months I lasted a few weeks
they took me off the couch in three days
three days I was off the couch I tried
to talk my way back on I try to get
myself kinda called Sam Jackson you know
the actor Sam of course he's old buddy
and I said listen Sam you can help me
out here I said you know and guests were
canceling right and left biggest level
show like I'm talking week one and I'm
not exaggerating I tell you guys week
one the lead guest on the fourth day on
a Thursday on week one was Suzanne
Somers with a new ThighMaster
that's how the a-listers bring in Jack
Nicholson all the a-listers and that was
the lead guest that I said I know how to
get back on the couch I'm gonna get Sam
Jackson I called Sam I go Sam we do this
is a favor
yoshua because nobody publicist said
don't do that show and I said please do
it for me it might get me back on the
couch you know I bring in a list there
he goes all right I'll do it but you
can't tell them that you can't tell them
that I'm you know he can't list me as a
guest like I like it more of a surprise
a surprise so I designed this thing
where I'm thinking oh I'll show them I
can produce and everything so I said
okay and I walked in the office and I
said listen to his agent you know the
executive producer I said listen uh I
got Sam Jackson really I'm getting back
in the couch up but you can't announce
him he goes no we can't do that okay
what do you mean you can't do that I
said those are the rules he won't do the
show otherwise
however he goes magic doesn't like
surprises you're not gonna get he's kind
of like surprises he's gonna like this
one
really it doesn't have to be a surprise
for magic magic just can't say it yeah
no no no no it was a surprise for me oh
it had to be a surprise that was the
design I did I did this thing where it's
really surprise him and it ended up to
be wearing this argument and he pounds
on the desk going magic doesn't like
surprises oh my god it's like grade
school so then he finally gave in and
they so we did we produced this segment
yeah where I prep the band I said hey
look at Mitch do pulp fiction you know
Sammy Jack's coming out I said you know
I'm on the air now live with magic I go
you know what you need some golf lessons
I said how about Sam Jackson gives your
golf lessons and Sam comes out with
clubs for me magic him we're having a
great time they took me off the couch
at least I made it through that section